veamos si podemos realizar la derivada
de 2 a la equis respecto de x y bueno tú
podrías decirme espero momento nosotros
ya sabemos cómo se realiza la derivada
de elevada la equis pero ahora la base
es 2 y como nosotros podríamos saber qué
hacer y el secreto aquí sería como
podríamos reescribir 2 a la equis así
que lo que esencialmente tenemos que
hacer es encontrar un e a alguna
potencia para que la clave sea
reescribir dicho 2 a la equis y bueno
podríamos pensar en que es lo que
nosotros necesitamos para entonces
elevar la e a alguna potencia entonces
en este caso podrá ser y el logaritmo
natural de 2 y el hecho de elevarla a
este logaritmo esto nos va a dar
simplemente el 2 y como lo dije
anteriormente esto es 2 puesto que es lo
que nosotros necesitamos es una forma de
reescribir lo entonces ya tenemos
nuestro 2 que está reescrito y ahora
vamos a elevar esto a la equis o sea
también el logaritmo natural de 2
x que lo voy a poner de color amarillo
entonces si ahora comienzo por acá a
hacer algo veamos que esta es la
derivada respecto de x de 2 a la equis y
lo que aquí vamos a poder usar es poner
dicha derivada al respecto de x pero con
lo que ya habíamos reescrito en lugar
del 2 a la x vamos a escribir la y
elevada a logaritmo natural de 2 a la x
como potencia y pues bueno aquí la x
estaremos usando la del mismo color
también ahora si tú recuerdas nosotros
ya tenemos algunas antiguas propiedades
de cuando nosotros elevamos algo a
alguna potencia pero que después lo
volvemos a elevar a otra potencia o sea
tienes una base la elevas a una potencia
y luego esta a otra o sea que tuviéramos
un número a una base a elevado a la vez
y ésta a su vez al hacer sea igual que
tener esta a la b por c entonces
nosotros podemos utilizar dicha
propiedad y llevarla a nuestro ejemplo
para poder escribirlo y tendríamos lo
siguiente tendríamos la derivada
de equis y adentro tendríamos el elevado
a logaritmo natural de 2 pero x x
entonces sería el logaritmo natural de 2
x x que igual lo voy a escribir de color
amarillo y vas a decir bueno y aquí lo
nuevo que fue pero lo interesante es que
utilizamos la elevado a alguna potencia
más simple para más adelante poder
nosotros utilizar la regla de la cadena
y siguiendo con esto si tú recuerdas la
derivada de la x viene siendo
exactamente lo mismo en esta ocasión
tenemos que contar con que hay un
coeficiente del lado de la x entonces
aquí vamos a tener la misma
elevada al logaritmo de 2 que a la vez
está x x y después vamos a tener que
derivar dicho coeficiente pero primero
aquí abajo voy a escribir lo más claro
que sería la derivada de e a logaritmo
natural de 2 x x respecto
y logaritmo respecto a que me equivoqué
respecto de logaritmos de 2 por x la
base de esto viene siendo que tenemos la
he elevado a algún x pero como había
comentado esto está detenido de algún
coeficiente que está de su lado entonces
aquí vamos a utilizar el producto y
aplicarlo del producto puesto que como
tú sabes ya estamos aplicando la regla
de la cadena entonces tenemos que hacer
ahora la derivada del coeficiente y en
este caso la derivada sería del
logaritmo natural de 2 y es respecto de
x pero pues en este caso ese sea el
coeficiente por lo que me quedaría
entonces la derivada del logaritmo
natural de 2 que está x x respecto de x
así que lo que hicimos fue simplificar
las cosas todavía un poco más pues esta
cosa de aquí la podemos volver a
reescribir como bueno voy a pintar aquí
una línea para que no se confundan las
cosas pero esto de aquí como habíamos
mencionado en un principio lo podemos
volver a poner con respecto a estas
propiedades que habíamos visto también
anteriormente
como a logaritmo natural de 2 que esto a
su vez está elevado a la equis exacto a
la equis y éste está multiplicando como
logaritmo natural de 2 pero que no
representaba la ha elevado a logaritmo
natural de 2 como tú recuerdas en esta
propiedad lo que hicimos fue reescribir
el 2 por lo que esto es 2 entonces esto
ya lo podríamos ver de una forma
simplificada entonces esto sería igual y
haciendo un pequeño intercambio por la
propiedad del producto como el logaritmo
natural de 2 que está aquí por 2 a la
equis que es lo mismo que poner 2 a la
equis por el logaritmo natural de 2 y
este es nuestro resultado